a vasectomy i i i i can't
i mean
getting surgery in your head and getting
surgery in your
pleasure zone
you know whether that's penis vagina or
anus right and i said the clinical terms
so i can't get age restricted here and
we can't get demonetized because
youtube's throwing that [ __ ] out right
but in your
in under your penis and testicles okay
i'm very medical here in this podcast
because i don't want to get age
restricted right
so behind the testicles
and anus
and or past the penis right
you get a vasectomy what they do they
they basically clip your
wings right okay you know what i'm
talking about you can't get
women pregnant anymore and so he said he
got a a
a vasectomy and i'm like
why
i i can't wrap
my
head
around someone getting a vasectomy i
cannot wrap my head around it okay
now he's done having kids he's had kids
he's with the same one he's with his
wife you know he doesn't want to have
any more kids and that's pretty final
right so first of all there's the whole
thing what if you change your mind okay
fine you could guess go get another
surgery and get it reversed fine okay
but also dude
just pull out
all right
because then they're not sticking knives
all in your pleasure zone
huh
because then you don't have to have
another guy
poking around in your pleasure zone with
something sharp like an exacto blade
really do it
really
just pull out little earlier
and i said this to him and he said well
the
um
the
idea of
not pulling out and having an orgasm
inside my
wife wow sounds worse when you're
clinical with it really to be honest i
mean
splurting sounds way less gross to me
right um
he says gets me so excited and i go huh
so excited to have eggs to have exacto
blades sticking around all inside your
you're right
really close to your anus and he says
yeah and he said it was three weeks
later and he still feels numb down there
ha
just pull out
dude i do it so early
right when i don't i mean when we don't
want to have kids i do it so early
i do it so early i could like read a
magazine in between when i pull out and
when i oopsie daisy
i mean seriously dude i read a whole
magazine of uh [ __ ] uh cosmopolitan
pull out
read a whole magazine
[ __ ]
l magazine before i oopsie daisy you
know what i'm talking about
i mean jesus dude
i swear to god i'll pull out i'll read a
whole app i'll find out what's wrong all
in the back of highlights before i oopsy
daisy do it
i swear to god
man i'll pull out i'll do the new york
times crossword puzzle not even on a
sunday before i oopsy daisy
that's the hard version sunday's easy
one
but i mean god damn dude
how are you bad at pulling out you know
why you're bad at pulling out cause it
feels too good
you
chump
back
up back up dude still feels good
what's up i mean bacon's amazing it's
not even like the difference between
bacon and turkey bacon turkey bacon
[ __ ] sucks dude
turkey bacon sucks the only realness
with bacon is the real bacon dude if you
have crispier [ __ ] and by the way dude
you better crisp that up that's like
that's like squirting all up in it
crispy bacon dude
pulling out
early it's still kind of it's like bacon
that's not that
crispy but it's still banging
it's not even like the turkey bacon
it's not like eating turkey bacon dude
it's not like eating vegan cheese it's
not like it dude
because you're still splurting
i could never get a surgery
i would never get an elective an
elective surgery i guess no mine was
medical i needed the doctor said my life
would be shorter if i didn't get it so i
got it he said i could die later on he
said you want to be around with your
kids way longer i said yep so i got it
but i just can't imagine getting a
vasectomy dude i'll just pull out man
or stuff some cotton up there or
whatever you know what i mean it's like
[Music]
put a split or where you know condoms
you know what they're not i mean i would
work you know i would do that i mean
surgery dude
crazy
also they don't always work imagine you
got the vasectomy and it didn't work
dude you got the vasectomy and you still
splurted and then you got a kid and the
kid shows up and you're like well we did
we actually no but we do love you
i i'm sorry
yes but got it
but we like we do it we actually love
you
so crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]